we kind of get like pigeonholed yeah as
housewives like this is your character
this is your and then you like kind of
or like play up to it or something
right right but i'm not i'm not doing
that
i
like to party
jesus this is unwaxed get in loser we're
going shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone do we just become best friends
um
are you done chewing sofia that's not
gum this isn't asmr what are you chewing
i'm chewing
prima gummy vitamins because i'm
stressed out the fact that we have a
bunch of guests today and we have to
shoot more tonight
no it's a lot like wait how do they
taste they're so good no honestly
they're so good they kind of taste like
a little bit of a starburst consistency
well let's see it says chill out relax
and unwind take the edge off anytime
anywhere
yeah oh good sounds good to me i am and
i like anything
that can make me calm
taste sweet especially after i eat
dinner and stuff i need something like
nice yeah that little sugar cake yeah
especially if you go to bed you want to
feel calm it's kind of a good well it's
kind of a perfect balance because not
only do they have products to help you
sleep
you're getting that little sugar fix
yeah and you're getting relaxed before
bed it's kind of the perfect thing
anyways i'm really not kidding when i
say they're actually really good and i'm
excited to see how i feel because i am
pretty stressed out today and that's why
at least 75-90 doctor visits are from
stress related issues which is wild
that's an insane number
well
sophie and i can obviously attest to
this many of us are operating on
survival mode we expect our skin our
bodies our minds to thrive especially
being on camera when honestly we're
running on empty all the time yeah
that's why we use prima because it's
california based and it is a new
purpose-led cbd brand that is just
targeted to make you feel your calmest
and best they are dedicated to help you
rise above modern day stress so every
day is a little bit better with our
doctor formulated clinically validated
high performance products for the skin
body and mind i want to keep eating
these gummies but if you guys don't know
where to start other than the gummies
which i highly recommend you can always
take those daily capsules that just help
you be calm throughout the day or if you
want i'm trying to find the name of it
it's called sleep tight because i know
that she struggles with this but we are
insomniacs we don't sleep so this has
been amazing to our sleep house this is
actually the only thing that has worked
and i've tried nearly every product on
the market in prima's sleep cbd
chef's kiss
so i hope you guys are already convinced
enough about this and so lucky for us
prima is offering our listeners an
exclusive limited time 20 off offer with
the code unwaxed so please you guys do
yourself a favor and get calm by going
to prima.co and using the code word
unwax to get that 20 off limited time
offer
guys come on if i'm saying that this
tastes like a starburst yeah
and you're gonna be calm get the relief
you guys deserve and you can feel better
every day sounds pretty good to me
all right sophia's walking in right now
get your ass in this chair it's time to
intro
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwaxed podcast
with your favorite sisters
sistine and sophia
wow i haven't seen you that energetic in
an intro in a long time no it's count
i'm trying to counteract the cbd i just
ingested
fair enough fair enough welcome back you
guys here another week in new york
another episode we're so excited about
our guest today i mean we keep saying
that every time do you know what i was
thinking about we tell our guests at the
end of every episode or the beginning of
every episode how we are so excited and
you're the special one for us but you
know what's the problem is we i had
that's so funny you said that because
i'm gonna catch up no no this thing i
feel like our audience is gonna start
catching on and then they're gonna call
us out for that but we're not saying i
promise you guys we're not saying it
just to say it well we are you get
excited every guest that wants to come
on they're probably thinking they're
just trying to suck the fart out of my
ass because we are just kissing butts
left and right no but we really are
excited about every single person you
know i think it's because we know that
it's they take time out of their day
they're driving to the studio getting
interviewed for an hour and it's for
free and when we're not paying these
guests to come on we're like who pay
them tequila bottles and cookies but we
do pay them with techies we do we do
give them some tequila bottles because
you know we love tequila but we do
actually care about it so i'm just
hoping you guys if you've caught on to
that it all comes from the heart you
know what
i guarantee no one caught on and we just
made them aware of listen no no we you
you brought this
up fair enough
so i've been obsessed i just want to
bring this up because i know we love
talking about tv shows reality shows and
one i'm getting hooked on once again
because it's been out for so many
seasons is
married at first sight and i just don't
know
where people find
the
confidence to put their trust in three
reality show therapist tv stars to
choose who they're gonna marry legally
it's actually so smart without knowing
their name
without knowing what they look like
their background nothing there's so many
shows today like
kissing at first sight married at first
sight there's the love is blind there's
so many blo now why does everything have
to be you can't see the person there's
so many shows now that teen mom i'm just
kidding i don't know
oh man did you watch that recent like
teen mom i don't know if it was teen mom
or i didn't know i was pregnant that
show that show rocks
how do you not know how do you not know
i mean i watched one the other day i've
had my bloating moments where i'm like
considering i'm like three possible like
it's a burrito or a baby
you've done a susquehanna cauliflower or
it is a child yeah it's been a crazy
weekend we don't know either one but i
was watching one recently and she was
kind of young and she said that she just
felt crampy and not really like herself
but nothing dramatic she honestly
thought she was just putting on weight
and then she was
in the bathroom one evening
and just
surprised new family members without a
baby essentially it's pooped out of me
imagine pushing so hard
you know what i don't know
women that can give birth without an
epidural
good on you how do you do it they
probably take primo before but i've also
hurt
i can't chill them out they're like pop
a couple gummies in there we're good no
but i i think about the first of all the
needle for an epidural is insane and
it's supposed to go into your spine but
i've always heard from pregnant women
that they don't even care at that point
because you're in so much pain
that you're just like give me the
epidural i don't know how i feel about
childbirth
i don't know how i feel you know what
i'll tell you do you remember this i
didn't want kids for years growing up
years
years watch listen to this because you
remember this moment
i remember we're watching home videos on
some old camcorder and this was probably
when i was like 10
or 11 whatever it was and um over one of
the tapes i guess my aunt had shot my
mom's birth of scar like scarlett's
birth
and that's why i remember this possible
place to shoot it right
so
you guys you saw everything i
and it was an accident
lost my mind and vowed to never have a
child because if that's what it looks
like
this is what i'm i can't do it listen
not judging anyone to each their own
me however
i don't think i could let my partner be
in the room because once you see it you
can't he can no he can be in the room he
got to be behind the curtain no i want
mine in the lobby the wizard of oz
behind the curtain you don't need to
know what's behind there my husband's
gonna be in the food court getting a
sami
get the sandwich chilling out when the
baby's all wiped and clean
the buried over the baby you're going to
be there you're going to be there oh
yeah are you okay i'm probably going to
be the one birthing it come and be like
all right team
i watch enough grey's anatomy dammit i
know i have to cut your kids umbilical
cord that's what i'm supposed to do why
do first of all first of all when did i
ever say that you were gonna be well
you're gonna trust scarlet with scissors
near you or your baby i'm not trusting
you either
tricia cut
our our aunt cut mom's
oh so it's yeah your family member can
do it it's not hard do you want to cut
my umbilical cord i want to cut you to
be honest sometimes so yeah it'll be the
closest thing perfect okay well i can't
wait to cut yours you know
i'm going to cut it out it's crazy i'm
going to like half do it and just kind
of like tease you like
cut a snowflake out
make it a lasso okay you know what i've
been watching
i have a bad habit of repeating shows
because i'm uncreative and don't want to
start something new so i've restarted
breaking bad
i love
jessie pinkman yeah you know they're
they're best friends and jesse pinkman i
don't actually know his real name so i'm
gonna go back brian cranston right no
that's walter white
aaron paul aaron but it isn't the guy
that plays yeah brian cranston yeah
aaron paul made brian aka walter white
his uh baby's
godfather yes
wow how sweet is that that's actually
really nice i know that's really who
would be your godmother god mother fury
kid
it does it have to be a friend or can it
be a family member
oh i don't know you know i i actually
have no idea well it just kind of
depends like what if you have a mental
breakdown later in life and i just can't
trust you or what if you're a good
person i'm not i'm like i'm already set
in the list i think god parents can be
see i don't know if i'd want my kid
cause you're so straight you're gonna be
such a strict mom you're gonna do
everything by the books best schools my
kid is gonna go to bed at six o'clock
perfect yeah but yeah that's a little
stressful for my kid my kids can have a
hair out of place see my kids middle
child energy a little bit of both but
scarlett's so far
to the insane side of the spectrum where
you know her kid is going to miss school
every day well i i feel like i'll have
to have a husband that's a little bit
chill he can be the chill dad i can be
the mom that is the one that the kids
get mad about and yeah to dad about
speaking of scarlett speaking of scarlet
yeah
scarlett um
planned herself a really fun 20th
birthday yeah
and
she goes i'm gonna rent a boat in miami
have all my friends and sophia and are
like this sounds sick i'm like wait that
sounds awesome i love your bikini let me
pick up my outfit yeah here we go um
yeah she did invite us
no
and she also celebrated a month early
and now knowing that happened she also
has her birthday coming up so that means
she's gonna have two birthdays this
child is a genius she really does she's
a genius she finesses mom and dad hard
she does it's only it's a youngest child
they do not they get whatever they want
whatever she wants if i asked for a boat
for my birthday
two months ahead of time they send you a
tugboat
i'd get a connection do you want a
banana boat no they'd give you a boogie
board you would be rubbing it they'd
give you a boogie board you might not
even use your body body surf
arm floaties
you need that but when did we become the
not cool sisters
like look at i'm the life of the party
this look at we're at a studio oh we did
this we're in new york we're cool we're
in newark
york
where's the pizza
[Music]
you know our our guest is a true new
yorker today and she would be ashamed to
hear our terrible actions i'll make sure
not to say what i just said so ever
again even though we just had a whole
spiel of saying we're excited about
every single person we have on we truly
are
once again so stoked about this person
because you know sophia and are avid
reality tv watchers big reality tv stars
and she just so happens to be
one of our favorite characters on the
housewives of new york
so stay tuned
[Music]
okay you guys i'm schvitzing right now
cause if you follow sophia and i you
know on the show how excited we are
about this next guest she is one of our
favorite reality shows
real housewives of new york recently she
released her memoir chaos theory finding
meaning in the madness one bad decision
at a time such an epic name and
she is the designer and creator of the
clothing brand mary to the mob this is
the badass leah mcsweeney
studio
audience
okay
i actually love
and i'm i'm not just saying this because
you're here i literally love you like
came on to the show and we're the source
of entertainment you gave that show a
facelift literally literally yeah
they're so fun to watch i want to get
into all of it but before we even
started rolling we have a freaky amount
of things yeah i really do cause now i
need to know birthdays okay i need to
know what like because we're talking
about astrology and her sister's a
cancer and so is sistine and i'm a virgo
and so is she okay what's your sister's
birthday wait oh yeah my daughter's a
gemini and you're my sister's a
gentleman right exactly oldest blondes
her other sister brunette yeah i mean
it's just as weird it's really weird so
what's your sister's birthday june 30th
oh from june 27th wow okay wow let's see
ours at the same time one two three
august 27th
[Music]
oh my
god like weird i don't think anyone with
27. i have barely met anybody with
august 2017
like maybe twin flames in a different
life [ __ ] yeah that's weird we're gonna
be very i can tell we're already pretty
somewhere i know this is really weird
wait that's like too much and now you
understand the dynamic between like our
family members because you have like
sister that's a cancer right daughter
that's a gemini yeah yeah and it's a lot
of literally those are the most
big signs i would say just like they're
the most extra of their signs you know
like virgos were so heady but we're so
opinionated and like very stubborn
super emotional oh my god i know i'm so
sensitive so but you know what a cancer
is but they can't i was gonna say i love
to roast but if you roast me back like
are you like that is so rude yeah like
are you kidding me i'm scared
for you like you're gonna insult me and
i don't know what your daughter is like
but i know with our sister scarlett she
is like you don't know what you're gonna
get with her like sometimes she'll have
100 energy in something or she'll
completely shut off and be yeah i don't
feel like doing it totally you know my
daughter i feel like we already
just know each other i know really
strange i guess you guys don't even need
to ask me anything i know you know
everything about me already thank you
see you next week
so funny so already meeting you in
person sometimes when you see someone on
tv and then you meet them in person it
could be totally different
you're very accurately represented on
the show as you are in person you're
super sweet so fun first impression
amazing right do you think that the show
accurately represented you i do i think
the second season i didn't get
the greatest edit i think they showed me
i was i had a hard season 13 because
like i was like not happy and like
dealing with like my grandmother's death
and like the pandemic
and
the the edits showed me i went from
being angry to sad a lot and they didn't
show me sad
they showed me angry because that's like
more interesting right like that me just
like crying being like i miss my
grandmother so they only showed me angry
yeah and not sad and like that part
sucks but also
was i angry yeah so like that was you
know you can't put every single total
thing that you film into the show
so
you know i think that i think the first
season
like being an actor obviously behind the
scenes like you have a script there's a
dialogue and you kind of know what
you're going to do going into it yeah
when you have a camera in your face and
you have to be yourself it changes a
hundred percent it's crazy and the
people are judging you for who you you
are not like some character you're
playing on tv everything that's your
dirty laundry is gonna come out and
that's the scariest part why would you
do that i know why would i want to do
that i guess it was just something i
felt like how do i say no to this like
how do i say no
yeah because it's like how many people
like get that opportunity
everyone wants to know what it's like
everyone has that like thought in their
head like what would it be like if
everyone knew who i was and i was on tv
why not and then you like
some people get that option and now i
have that and i'm like it's not that
great
i'm like okay i understand the thought
process because you started your
clothing brand married to the mob before
the show yeah you're also kind of
looking at it like this is a great
marketing of course completely
let's talk about the clothing round and
then we'll go right back into it mary to
the mob you're wrapping i'm actually
wrapping it up
thank you
i love it yes thank you where did the
name come from what made you want to
start so i started the brand when i was
22. oh my god i think yeah in 2004 and i
started the brand actually because i saw
that the like got my mail counterparts
that i was like hanging out with all had
brands streamer brands and they were
getting to travel for free oh and i'm
like i want to travel for free yeah like
they were going to europe they were
going to asia and like i had been to
paris i'd been a little to europe a
little but i was and i loved it and i
was like i need to travel more you know
and i'm like how am i going to do this
i'm like i'm going to start a brand so
you start it based on because you want
to travel here except obviously that was
like this you know that's actually crazy
that's hysterical because i like that
and then where why i'm married to the
mob
so i used to joke around and say that i
was like married to the mob because i
really was kind of like unemployable but
like was dating rob and kind of like
using his money to just like shop right
and like yeah shop and like do my thing
and i really actually wanted to be like
his like
housewife yeah i wanted to be that and
then i ended up
being an entrepreneur and like a
businesswoman and i mean that's great
but also like you know it's a lot of fun
you can just do whatever you're like
okay let me go buy this the universe
took me in a whole different direction
with the brand and it just like took off
well it knew that you could handle it
did you get to travel did it work out to
travel there we got a lot of places
when you were young going to well my
favorite probably was the trip i took to
malta with my sister which wasn't really
business related but it was just like it
was so cool it was one of the best trips
and i always talk about doing sister
trips and like we got to make these
memories we could tell our kids remember
that time
all the time ended up in a stripper hot
tub like just crazy yeah me and my
sister have a lot of those that's what i
say we really do
need those memories and it's so nice
like you understand like having a sister
do you work with her ever like on the
brand did she do something totally done
no she does something totally different
she's on the show a bit too does she
like
shows it you know my sister's very like
my sister's the smartest person i know
and like i don't think that the audience
really understands her like right right
some people do but like some people
don't like they're just like why is she
like a witch and she's weird i'm like
she's just so much smarter than all of
you like it's really simple like she's
just like on another yeah she gets it
yeah yeah there was a lot of family
dynamic that went on with your storyline
and especially your second season
there was a tumultuous relationship with
your parents yeah that must have been
really hard
to air because by the way
behind closed doors everyone has [ __ ]
with their parents but no one wants it
blasted on tv i know so what was that
like going through it i think that like
you know i've always been an open book
and like i
i think maybe i over share that's like a
coping mechanism of mine so it wasn't
hard for me i'm a chatty kathy like if i
have a problem i need to talk about it
yeah i can't explain it and also like
i'm just gonna tell you what's wrong
with me up front right so you can figure
out if you don't like me or not now is
that your tactic with dating you're like
yeah this is all my issues yes so if you
like it then stay with that 100 points
some guys love it and some guys are like
bye but that's that's kind of what you
do with the girls on the show as well
and i think yeah they all just judged
you right off the bat because you were
so vocal about sex and like you were an
extrovert and yeah you were much younger
than all of them like all right yeah and
i've talked about sex too they were just
like they talk about come on
like they talk about sex so much like
eye [ __ ] people but like she does and i
don't like she does the whole like thing
like this you know that's the whole
hypocrisy of what me and her have going
on just how she said liberally does
sexual things doesn't mean she doesn't
talk about sex like that is the same
thing just different like languages you
know what i think it's like we kind of
get like pigeonholed yeah as housewives
like this is your character this is your
and then you like kind of or like play
up to it or something right right right
but i'm not i'm not doing that like i
think they want me to right that's why
they're like you're always talking about
sex you're always and i'm like no i'm
not right right so they kind of oh god
it's like gaslighting you like they're
kind of riling you up like they're like
you're doing this and i'm like no i'm
actually not but i'm not like
with the show when people start to like
me comments about the things you would
do or say whatever it doesn't even
matter did you ever feel like you had to
filter yourself at any point or were you
just still sticking with your guns um i
mean i i actually like said on national
television that i didn't want to vote so
i don't think i filtered myself yeah
because like if there's one thing that
you don't say like it's like that's not
you know so
i just i can't lie right like i can't
not perfect reality but also i just
can't like that's also why you're so
likable though because there's an
authenticity that also i'd rather people
be like well you know what you're
[ __ ] an irresponsible [ __ ] and i
hate you right let me be like oh yeah
i'm early voting guys like and be like
good good girl we love you yeah like i'd
rather you hate me for who i am than
love me for someone that i'm pretending
today have you always been like that
because that is like you gotta have some
thick skin to be that like oh i mean i'm
a mess most of the time over here no but
you're
especially when it's judging like who
you truly are you're like okay people
hate me for me like like they really do
and i'm a people pleaser too like i'm
very like all i want to do is kind of
people pleaser though see i'm a people
pleaser thing yeah so i'm always happy
about like making sure that i'm saying
the right thing doing the right thing
but it's also really hard for me to not
be myself and what's also on the show is
you can't really fake what you do
because everyone can pick up on it if
you're trying to miss goodie t-shirts
people on the people that's stupid is
there a moment that aired on tv that you
were like [ __ ] i shouldn't have should
have done that i mean maybe that that
voting one i mean i was like i could
have just got the
no just like i was like you know what i
don't need to like
like carry the torch and like be this
sacrificial lamb of like i'm speaking
for millions of people who you know what
i mean like i'll do it um i don't know
there's really not that much where i was
like oh i wish i hadn't done that that's
well that's why that's good that's
probably the best answer to give there's
things i wish i would have done okay
that you would have done you know what i
mean like yeah i wish that i would have
um
said
more actually i think i held back a bit
season 13. really i think i was walking
on eggshells a little i saw that and i
wish that i had like been a little more
vocal i just feel like you had a target
on your back all the time you were just
like waiting for you to open your mouth
just to strike you that's right that's
how i felt are you going back for
another season yeah i don't know wait
how does that even work because i'm
curious are you saying you don't know do
they just like do they call you
very like last minute really
would you do it again
yeah yeah i would
yeah he sound hesitant yeah i would no i
would you know it's like now there's two
shows that got split into two right
right right
so there's two shows but now they're
splitting it into two shows it's like
wait really yeah it's the whole thing
like it's like a whole thing it's like
two different you get like which one you
want to be no i don't think it goes that
way i wish like
i wish i had that much juice that's
basically i'm like well i can't yeah i
don't know which one i'm gonna go on i
don't know if i'm gonna go on either of
them and also
me wanting to go on it would be
dependent upon upon who's on those shows
right yeah because at the end of the day
i do need to be having fun yeah
absolutely you know or else that's the
point of doing it exactly well i would
like to see you on another season me too
and also and you could talk about your
new book that's coming out which i
really want to talk about give us the
listeners just some insight of why you
decided to write it what's it about okay
so chaos theory um
finding meaning in the badness one bad
decision at a time is a memoir but it's
very self-reflective it's not like
prescriptive like how to like
this is how you find inner peace and get
sober or whatever right but i do talk
about how i found inner peace how i
found sobriety or how i'm still looking
for inner peace or whatever so
and it's very reflective and it really
starts it talks a lot about like my 20s
and my 30s until present time i don't go
too into like
like my childhood and stuff right right
right like a little bit growing up in
the city and things like that but and
it's really about like mental health and
addiction yeah right that's mainly and
how long have you been sober so far so i
haven't had a drink in over two years
wow but i restarted my day count because
i was smoking weed and now i'm like not
doing that so that you consider that as
counting well for me i don't judge
anyone else yeah i can do whatever
totally totally you know but it's like i
need to really like needed to completely
like yeah all that [ __ ] out that's um
hard to do yeah it really is especially
when you're like in athens and like you
really want to not be in your own brain
most of the time you know what what
would you want to like switch to being
sober was there something on the show
you you were drinking in the beginning
like the first time you were on it yeah
but that was like i had had nine years
sober before that and then and then i i
started drinking before i got casted on
the show why was that
i don't i just started drinking wait
like i'm in a
i think i can do this different now i
couldn't clearly watch season 12. was it
watching this by the way
honestly it was the torches it was fun
and i'm really glad that her body
like was actually like had some amazing
like two contacts
yeah absolutely the best
ever was it watching the show that means
you want to switch for us it just so you
guys actually quit drinking two days
before the show aired really so i didn't
even wow so then you like watched it i
had no idea if people were going to like
me i had no idea what was going to end
up in the show
i stopped drinking because the pandemic
happened yeah i was like in a [ __ ]
house with my daughter and my ex and my
sister and her baby and i was like i'm
drinking a lot and my ex was like rob
was like this is not how this [ __ ] is
right right right right yeah like i'm
not sure when you're all locked in the
open yeah and i was like oh [ __ ] i
better how do you have such a good
relationship with your ex i feel like
how does it work
none of mine want to talk to me anymore
honestly i don't want to talk to any of
them except for him why don't you but
you know why don't you guys get together
as unless he's married i just don't want
to suck his dick oh okay
literally
that's like what i said like he's not
your type
like well now he's you know i mean
yeah not anymore like i like the way 26
year olds live now i mean i'm sorry
i mean i find myself being attracted to
younger guys wait so how are you finding
younger guys in the city right now are
you on a nap they're [ __ ] hot like by
the way i was telling sophia today i was
just walking the streets i'm like hot
hot everyone's attractive here me and my
daughter play this game ooh i love your
dog media my
we always like take walks up the west
side highway yeah that's where like it's
like it's all central is that where i
should be that's my friend told us to go
i'm going out guys have their shirts off
they're jogging and so we do this game
of like who would you date and like so
it'll be like no no yes yes and just
like mom what about that one she's
saying no no yes have you ever picked
someone on the bus like well i don't
talk to them we just like say to
ourselves yes yes
i love really she is so pretty fun i
love your
daughters so fun i love that like she's
so cool and it was her idea
do you feel like you birthed say let's
play this game
she's my i know
i know my best friend that's really cute
is she allowed to start dating
you know she's um she's allowed to like
do i mean not do whatever she wants but
she's so good like yeah she's a good
girl she's a good girl like i give her
like a late curfew sometimes like if
she's out and she's like i want to stay
out i'll be like okay come home at 12
which my mother's like that's [ __ ]
great that's a very
nice girlfriend i know we had a ten
third yeah we had ten thirty but i'm
like i just i don't know like i just
don't want her to i don't wanna cage her
in like i don't wanna do it you know
there is something to be said about not
putting so much restraint in the kit
because i feel like there's some times
where you say no no no and all you want
to do is just do it you know exactly we
yeah we've had so many friends we've
heard so many stories of their parents
just driving school into them making
them stay home you have to study you
have to get these grades and then they
end up just being the craziest ones i
know and you know what she is on honor
roll like she is she loves to sew she's
like a fashionista in the making awesome
she's really like pretty special are you
dating right now no oh you're not i've
only had sex once in the last 12 months
with the 26 year old and i decided
to myself by saying i'm sex positive as
negative as a tagline i [ __ ] myself
this guy's so good you've like quit all
sex no i stopped always so bad you're
like i need to be no he does not she
said she loves 26 year olds he got too
attached oh
do you think that's what happens with
these younger guys maybe that was the
only one look at her yeah
like i was just like you
you have voodoo clam
that's mesmerized it's hypnotized
once they make eye contact they're like
locked for life
but you attach so you don't feel like
casually doing you're like at a place
where like you know what if it works it
works no i mean i would i just like i'm
not like i'm so busy right now yeah yeah
like i really am i'm still like into
like myself right now i love i feel like
you're great at flirting
yeah i am like what's your tactic do you
have like i just i'm actually really
[ __ ] like overt like i'm just i'll be
like what's your sign
like what you know i was just like i'm
super like into like just paying
attention and like asking questions yeah
that's what it is but
i
can't flirt sober so do you have
different like tactics now because like
obviously when you're tipsy it's really
like easy to do yeah like it's a totally
different battle maybe actually why i
haven't been laid too much because i've
stopped doing it
because if i get rejected tipsy i'm like
i don't care like
when
right
meeting guys you're usually at a bar you
can go like let's go get drinks
like i'm not really going to bars and if
i go to bars they're literally gay bars
or drag queen bars exactly did i not say
i wanted to go to a drag bar today yes
she did
go back to your book when you said that
you discussed your early 20s and the
lessons and everything that you learned
sophie and i are in our early 20s
what do you think your biggest like
regret was in your early 20s or
something that you look back like what i
was on i i was like
searching for like validation in all the
wrong places
where were you looking for like for in
with dudes right for sure and like
i mean look me and rob were actually
together so i didn't really start doing
that until we broke up and i got to like
kind of relive and like have my early
20s like towards the end of my 20s more
just like picking the wrong guys and
like i had i tolerated so much [ __ ] and
like yeah now i would never like if a
guy like is like not into me i'm like
okay cool you're like okay
like i would leave him alone
what's going on like why don't you like
me like what's happening like i feel
like confidence just comes with age yeah
right like i feel like i'm i i know
myself now but i still
seek validation from men and i don't
fully think i'm like
perfect yet or like i don't know i mean
the thing is i'm still insecure like i'm
still insecure because like everybody is
and that's human like right except for
luanne count to slow man
is that real confident yeah what is up
with that that can be i don't know it's
like
i
borderline
know it's it's it's interesting it's
really interesting are you friends with
any of them from yeah i love luanne like
when i say so i'm saying that with all
like i love y'all i mean i want to
outside
like
when i it's wild really oh yeah and when
you if i actually if i really wanted to
get laid i could call her and go to a
bar that woman knows how to pick up men
and she's still good right
i'm not sure okay whatever but
regardless she still was able to even
when she was on the show we're not sober
like she can do it you should do that
yeah yeah
i just feel like older guys so this is
this is the issue i did i found she
found this hot guy for me we were making
out the whole night i go to the bathroom
i come back she's [ __ ] sucking face
with them no shut the f she's not yeah
she is did you freak out i was laughing
oh come on i would be so pissed like
i thought it was hilarious i'm like okay
i see i see you lulu she was like let me
just see if she likes somebody no she's
like let me show you i might be older
than you [ __ ] but i still got it and
you need to know that like i'm
accountable well was he a good makeout
at least yeah he was he wanted to she
got your sloppy seconds
yeah exactly your eskimo sister and then
he was like i'm sorry i'm like it's okay
i don't care if i'm like i don't want to
make however you're not gonna do it
again i mean it was funny it was really
funny i was i wasn't mad how is dating
in the city though i know you haven't
been a lot of horrible horrible it's
like terrible it's pretty bad in l.a
recently i had a crush i actually had
met someone who really like and it was
very like organic that i met the way i
met him yeah through friends and
whatever
and he was flirting with me so much i'm
like is he flirting with me i'm like wow
he's calling me he's crashing me on the
book he like was watching my tamron hall
show video calling me telling me about
it and so finally i was like
just super like yeah like up front right
yeah and then he kind of pulled back and
so after passover when he was on his
phone again i was like so what's up like
i feel like we were flirting and then
like you stopped cause i'm like
i'm just gonna ask you i don't go
straight like i don't know why you're
not like so and he was like oh i'm sorry
like i we i owe you a coffee and like a
coffee like why are you talking to me so
formal what's going on he's like okay
i'm actually like i can't like marry a
convert or someone who's been divorced
because i'm a i'm like in this specific
act of judaism or whatever and i'm like
dude no judgment totally respected but
you knew i was a convert from the get-go
wait is there is there a part of judaism
where they can't marry converts yeah oh
i actually he's he's a cohen like a
cocaine and
right and so if he married a condor he'd
be giving up the status of the cohen but
i'm like dude listen i converted to your
religion so i i respect it i'm like i'm
right i've been judging you like dude
get yourself a non-divorced but just
jewish girls like you know before but
like damn i thought we were gonna smash
like what i thought like were gonna have
shabbat and then like yeah not touch any
electricity and just be boning all day
on a saturday night i was looking
forward to it wait why did you convert
that's an interesting question
i from a young age i've always been like
spiritually like seeking even when i was
a teenager on drugs i swear i had such
crazy like ex like
religious or spiritual experiences like
going to like the fourth dimension like
when i was on acid and like really like
look people will take mushrooms and take
um you know ayahuasca and do all that to
like bring them have you done ayahuasca
i have it and i would never will no um
i've been there already i don't need to
do it you know what i mean now at this
point in my life i don't think my brain
could handle it yeah
so i was always very like spiritual i
never minded i went to catholic school i
didn't mind it i loved praying but i
just never
connected with the jesus part oh okay i
just never
connected with that part with god yes
mm-hmm um but jesus not really and
that's no shade like my mother's a
devout catholic i respect it my daughter
goes to catholic school yeah we went to
catholic school
we went to catholic school and i think
it honestly depends on how the school
teaches it right do you think the way
that you learned it you were like i'm
not able to connect with you no i don't
i think you just was just when i would
pray i just prayed to god okay
and then as i got older these
specific pivotal things would happen
like when i was 18 this girl told me to
read a book called the red tent which is
about jacob's wives and i read that and
i felt very connected and then like i
started working with these orthodox jews
and i felt very connected learning about
all the traditions and
holidays and talking to rabbis and i
went to a hare krishna temple like i've
done a lot of stuff right now finally i
was like i'm converting to judaism
because like that's just what's in my
heart right yeah how's it been so far
great great
you know like i still don't know like
there's so much to learn yeah are you
gonna have a bat mitzvah i know my
jewish friends keep asking me this is
august 27th you should have
like maybe
some you guys will definitely be invited
definitely when you start thinking about
it
do you bring guys home to your parents
like
um still parents well sometimes like i
just haven't like met my mom's
i dated this guy for one year he was
irish jewish and my mom met him you know
my family met him a bunch of times since
we were dating for a year but like i
just haven't been dating and so on no
like do they do you need their approval
when you're dating someone because no
you're like
what are your daughter do you ever
introduce people to your daughter she's
rarely barely met anybody okay yeah i
always feel like that too if you were
like no you want to make sure it's like
a good one you know what she made me do
again she's a savage i love it i was on
hinge which i deleted because it's just
too depressing um and someone literally
wrote to me wow this is so sad you're on
tv and you're okay i was gonna say like
you honestly i can't hear you yeah i was
just saying like i have stories on hinge
or like well that guy that said that and
then someone being like someone wrote if
you're someone who watches reality tv
such as housewives please swipe left and
i was like oh that's so lame i know
you're like well i was on hinge and i
got about 30 messages that were like
rocky rambo's daughter
i have a boyfriend when i was on it
years ago people didn't believe my
profile is real they're like your fake
account i mean has anyone ever dated you
because you were on tv no because i
haven't been dating since i've been on
tv okay you're right yeah
that's right that's right but now in my
head i have that like i'm like is this
person just like like if i find someone
am i gonna know like i mean you guys are
not your thing anymore why are you going
for girls i know listen i've gone that
way also like when i was younger
and then not so younger but like i just
don't know if i can have a relationship
like i can like oh yeah sexually yeah
but i don't but maybe i can like i never
know how open to it i'm totally open to
it yeah and i've had you know
crushes and connections with women
before but just like not in a while and
i've never had a woman really be like
can i take you on a date like in that
romantic way
so i think like you don't know see
that's the thing it's like once the
opportunity is there you can like tell
more so what happened i felt energy
before from women where i'm like oh i
could see this right work like i
understand now like waking up like can i
envision myself waking up in the morning
and looking and there's like a woman
next to you that i love right
i love your openness about sex and like
what you're willing to talk about and
sharing we wouldn't be here if it wasn't
for you it's so different i still have
so many hang-ups about sex stuff yeah
you know like because we get so much
mixed messaging and it's like should i
be a [ __ ] should i not be like what do
you want me to be my value my values
based on how many men i've slept with
and it should be only three but also i
should be knowing how to take it from
every angle and like a porn star like
what is it i'm so confused well are you
gonna teach your daughter anything about
sex early on does she know a lot of
things because are you open with her
about sex oh yeah i mean she knows i
haven't had it in a while um she's like
she's like yeah she's like you know we
don't like she doesn't really want to
watch shows that have sex in them like
sometimes if there's a movie and there's
like a sex scene we're both like
yeah
right right right yeah weird right um
but she had questions don't be open to
like oh my god i would answer anything
for her you know she
like recently she we've been talking
about when she's gonna she's like when
i'm what am i gonna ever like a guy
because i haven't i'm like oh that
wasn't me no it's just i'm like you're
picky like you're picky and you're smart
and like
she's not looking for validation through
guys like some of the girls that she
knows or whatever and like that makes a
difference like you you're gonna
probably kiss someone later maybe down
the road you know what i honestly in my
like when i think about how i slept with
so many guys between breaking up with
rob and then like the next four years
like i went on a [ __ ] rampage i'm
thinking like most of these dudes like
literally seventy percent of the sex
i've had in my entire life i [ __ ]
didn't even like joy or like the guy
what makes it good though was it a
connection that you have to have with
someone beforehand do you think or do
you think they just have to have a movie
i think that it's a mixture of things
like there's one guy that like i had met
in spain and well there you go it's
gonna be back to spain
two weeks later
i flew back i didn't hook up with him
then but at the time later i flew back
because i was like i've gotta go and my
parents were like you're having a manic
episode i'm like this is not me media
this is me living my life guys
wait he flew to spain and then we sleep
with this guy yeah he was about of
course he's gonna be great he was oh my
god he took me to this restaurant where
there was an opera singer like that like
it's like an opera like a vibe
i'm on the
motorcycle like oh come on it was like
it was amazing it's a movie it's like
victory christina barcelona's dick was
humongous did you go through it like a
depressive period after that
oh like after because it was meaningful
because it was too great oh i thought
that was great because what am i gonna
do after him no but after that i
actually met a a guy who was 21. i was
31 at the time i met a 21 year old and
dated him for six months and he kind of
like
yeah and he wrote a terrible book about
me after that no we didn't out of here
how did you know it's about it's online
only it's not like published but someone
had sent me the link to it and wait what
did you say oh my god he was saying the
worst things about my mental health and
just talking about how like i went crazy
and and i then i didn't want to [ __ ]
because of the meds which was true
and then like i gave him a shitty
birthday present which i'm sorry i gave
you a goyard wallet i guess he didn't
like that
kidding me that's pretty nice oh my god
and they talk [ __ ] about rob i mean he's
terrible he gave every he gave us all
different names and he like gave my
brand a different name but they were the
cheesiest it's literally he's a terrible
writer
like at least
it was the most when he talked about the
sex parts too i was like he was like
i have to say
it was insane graphic it was it's
graphic af like i was like wow i guess
you're still holding on to this [ __ ] i'm
like 40. did you ever respond to him or
reach out and being like what the hell
is this you know what i actually wanted
to reach out and apologize because
yeah because i felt like i must have
done something so hurtful to him
maybe think he's just immature
i don't know i think i [ __ ] him up and
i think i oh i probably owe him an
apology that's what i got from them
yeah that's like nice i'm like calm it's
cussing out
she's like i can't help that i'm a game
changer in relationships i'm not girls
okay i am i'm sorry you can write books
but i am i felt bad i was like wow he
must be like he's really holding on to
this still like it's been awesome i must
have done some serious damage like wow i
saw on the show um you once
sexted with like a pita bread or
something like over your vagina pita
chip
me and him but it was the best thing
i've ever seen boy yeah oh did they show
the actual picture of me with the pita
bro
no i don't think so they didn't flash no
thank god i
because he owns a pita factory oh that's
right he owns a pizza factory and he had
dropped me off some pita oh that's his
stomach
a picture of me it's really good peta
actually
and like all the restaurants in new york
use like actually where i ordered from
last night i'm not eating bread right
now
i'm one of those girls right now i'm
like no bread no sugar so the pita came
i'm like kiki you want the pita she's
like no i was like all right does she
know no but she was like i'm not i don't
need any peter right now he's like you
sex
but it is really good
like are you big on sexting you think it
works or do you like not really
i yeah i think it's like if it's the
right vibe and like but i would rather
if it
some guys get too
like too graphic and descriptive it's
like yeah no i don't need something like
and then i'm gonna bend you over and
spread open your blah blah blah it's
like no you just just be like damn i
can't wait to like yeah [ __ ] like
that's cool but just i don't need that i
don't need a like a play-by-play yeah
yeah like a [ __ ] graphic look at that
if you said like a voice memo
well okay i hate those i hate you guys
i'm old so i like sending voicemails
but not like a lot of people get into it
like not doesn't say what else i've
never gotten one of those
you should send one and i should what
the [ __ ] am i going to say guys peter
chip the jewish guy that rejected me i
don't know there's so many like
you guys for testing out like let me
know if you think this is hot no because
i already know he would not know what to
say back he's not like creative or like
maybe like warm up send him like a
bitmoji like the moving like dog or
something
like i want you to do me doggies like a
dog oh my god like that's horrible
that's awesome oh you know what he lives
right by me he doesn't have a girlfriend
we have great sex i could have sex him
at any moment but i said to him he
didn't help me after my boob job when he
promised that he would and i was like
you're done i was like no matter if i
talk to you ever again you will never
ever [ __ ] me ever again i need help and
you're not allowed to say that and i
will never and you will never touch my
new tattoo you will never [ __ ] see my
eyes oh you will never get this [ __ ]
ever again and that's facts come over
and watch movies i'm like okay bye stop
stop that is you're good he's probably
like
does he call you like a tease he's like
no he just he's like really okay like
that's very sure i don't even know i
also don't want to like after that i was
like no you're not attracted turns you
off yeah i guess i just feel like right
now we should all just be in like a
reading erotica type phase or like write
some erotica and like yeah that's what
you should and yeah that's why i have
written erotica yeah i read i wrote last
year is it really publisher is it just
it was for um like a porn website you
stopped yeah
who like sells this app and she's so
rich and she's so used to like everybody
doing what she wants but she just wants
like someone to [ __ ] like take
dominance yeah
executive like oh you know those are
gonna be that'll do just fine wait yeah
you should make that like the next thing
though that would be really cool
i haven't seen like a really
kind of more pop culture erotica thank
god no one's done it in like you're not
like a cheesy like you have like the
perfect demographic too yeah you guys i
think i'm going to do this yeah i'm not
kidding like that okay completely fine
please don't do it
i'm writing it no seriously because no
i've been really wanting to write again
but i'm like do i write more about my
mental health i'm so over talking about
that well you did it and it's out there
and you would keep talking you're going
to ask me yeah i think you've done that
let's do something something different
something that's also interesting and
can keep your mind like fresh and always
thinking and also it can also tie in
mental health stuff too anyway really
sex is so tight into all and you know
what's really funny is on tick tock
there's this thing called book talk and
a lot of people are reading from like
tick tock book recommendations and a lot
of the books are smutty and spicy and a
lot of people like
adding sex into book sound yeah and i
mean if you kind of use that with
everything that people are becoming a
lot more open about it it's a lot of fun
to read i can't even imagine how much
fun you're going to have writings
oh my gosh our support i love a new
project i'm telling you that's a really
good idea all right so we got our next
project thanks guys
you guys are my career guru
i could literally talk to you for hours
you are so freaking awesome oh my gosh
tell everyone where they can find your
socials your book everything i'm not on
twitter because it's toxic af but you
can find me on instagram at leahmob you
can purchase chaos theory anywhere like
they sell books it's there and you can
buy married to the mob on um
mttmnyc.com and i also have a
sustainable sleeper company i'm going to
send you guys a bunch of stuff yeah yeah
absolutely called happy place brands and
you can also go to happyplacebrand.com
and help save the earth yeah and then
look out for her new erotica cups
on top of all you guys that's dedicated
to both of you main characters not named
sophia
she better be named sophia i don't know
i love it we love you guys and we'll see
you next tuesday
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you